الآلاف من المركبات الفاخرة لن تذهب
إلى روسيا في هذا الركن من قطعة أرض
مترامية الأطراف 200 كاديلاك
إسكاليد عالية القيمة تزيد عن 15
مليون
دولار ، غنائم العقوبات تتراكم حرفيًا
داخل زيبرا البلجيكي الضخم خطًا أماميًا جديدًا
في الحرب الاقتصادية الأوروبية مع
روسيا.  وكلاء الجمارك البلجيكيون
ضد الأوليغارشيين الخاضعين للعقوبات في روسيا ،
لقد قمنا بتجميد أكثر من 200 مليار
يورو من الأصول الروسية ، ولدينا أيضًا
سلع فاخرة أخرى تم
حظرها مؤقتًا ، وهناك
حاويات تم حظرها
لمزيد من التحقيقات ولكن من يملك بالفعل
هذه الأشياء الثمينة المصادرة وهل
يمكن بيعها  أصبح الحصول على أموال لدعم أوكرانيا
سريعًا سؤالًا ملحًا ،
خاصة في أوروبا التي تشعر
بالضيق الاقتصادي للحرب
الروسية ، هذه المركبات ليست مملوكة لروسيا حتى الآن ، لكن
هناك الكثير من الثروة الروسية التي
تقع تحت سيطرة الحكومة البلجيكية ،
وهناك بالفعل 2.7 مليار
أصول روسية تم حظرها  التي
تم تجميدها ثم أيضًا ما يقرب من 200
مليار أه تم تجميدها
والبضائع التي تم
حجزها حتى الآن ماذا يحدث
لمالكها بالطبع
يتم تجميد المعاملات والأصول
نفسها مجمدة بحيث لا يمكن استخدامها
بعد الآن لا يعني ذلك  أنهم أصبحوا
أن الحكومة تمتلكهم
وكل هذه المركبات التي ننظر إليها
جميعًا يقولون إن روسيا الوجهة
في محطة شحن zbrugger ، الرئيس مارك
أدريانسون على الخطوط الأمامية
لفرض عقوبات على
أي مركبة متجهة إلى روسيا تقدر قيمتها بأكثر من
يتم حجزها
من أجل  في اللحظة التي بدأنا فيها ثمانية آلاف
سيارة بدأنا العمل بثمانية آلاف
، هذا كثير جدًا
على الرغم من أننا يمكن أن نحصل
على المزيد ، يقول مائة وعشرون
ألف مركبة متجهة إلى روسيا
سنويًا عبور
ضوابطه بالفعل بعيدًا عننا نحن لسنا كذلك
هناك لتخزين السيارات ، نحن موجودون
للتعامل مع السيارات ولإحداث قيمة مضافة على
ضغط السيارات على أبناء أدريان ، وستزيد بلجيكا
الحرب بعيدًا عن
نهايتها والعلاقات التجارية  مع روسيا في عمق الربع الثالث
من العام الماضي ، كانت روسيا
أكبر شريك تجاري بحري للاتحاد الأوروبي
وفقًا لبيانات الاتحاد الأوروبي
وثلث كل تلك البضائع التي تأتي
عبر موانئ مثل هذه في بلجيكا
وفقط فوق الساحل في هولندا ،
يمكن أن تضيف جميعًا  ما يصل إلى مليارات الدولارات المحتملة
من البضائع التي يمكن استخدامها
لمساعدة أوكرانيا ولكن تحويلها إلى نقود
يتطلب مصادرة قانونية
ليست عملية سهلة
يتم تحذير البرلمانيين الأوروبيين من قبل
مسؤولي العدالة في الاتحاد الأوروبي لمصادرة ممتلكات شخص ما ،
نحن بحاجة إلى جريمة
نبحث عنها قانونية  حلول
غسيل الأموال
الاختلاس ربما يعاقب
على التحايل حتى ذلك الحين
سوف تتقادم البضائع والأصول البحرية
بينما يموت مقاتلو الخطوط الأمامية في أوكرانيا من
أجل أسلحة جديدة نيك روبرتسون
CNN Zbrugger بلجيكا